RUSSIA PROBE.
JOINING ME FOR REACTION IS
REPRESENTATIVE TREY GAUDY.
HE IS ON THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE AND THE ETHICES
COMMITTEE AND RUMOR HAS IT HE IS
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE 4-H CLUB
THERE AT CAPITOL HILL.
HE JOINS US FROM SOUTH CAROLINA.
FROM DALLAS CONGRESSMAN JOHN
RATCLIFF.
HE IS A FORMER UNITED STATES
HAPPY HOLIDAYS AND HAPPY NEW
YEAR.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
CONGRESSMAN, I WANT TO START
WITH YOU.
I HAVE BEEN IN YOUR SEAT.
I DEALT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WHEN THEY ARE NOT
IN ORDER TO GET THE JOB DONE
THAT YOU WANT TO GET DONE?
AS YOUR ACCESS TO DOCUMENTS AND
WITNESSES.
IN THIS CASE WE NEED 302s.
WHEN THE FBI INTERVIEWS SOMEONE
A 302, THAT'S THE NAME OF THE
FORM GENERATED.
WE NEED 1023s.
ANOTHER SUMMARY OF AN
INTERACTION BETWEEN AN FBI AGENT
AND A SOURCE.
WE NEED ALL OF THAT.
SO WE CAN PREPARE TO INTERVIEW
WHETHER IT'S A FORMER COUNCIL
BAKER OR PETER STRZOK OR LISA
PAGE.
-- TO ALL OF THE DOCUMENTS.
WE HAVE WAITED A LONG TIME FOR.
IT I USED TO WORK FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
IF I HAVE A BIAS IT'S TOWARDS
THEM.
THIS IS TAKING LONGER THAN IT
SHOULD AND NEEDS TO.
>> CONGRESSMAN, HAVE YOU BEEN A
UNITED STATES PROSECUTOR.
TO USE A FAMOUS LINE:
WHAT DIFFERENCE DOES IT MAKE.
YOU ARE ON THE
YOU ARE ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
YOU WERE THE TWO THAT GOT TO
INTERVIEW MR MCCABE, HOW DID
THAT GO.
>> THE REASON WE THE DEPARTMENT
DIRECTOR McCABE IN THE ROOM
RELATED TO THE PRIOR TESTIMONY
OF FORMER DIRECT JAMES COMEY.
YOU AND CHAIRMAN GOWEDY AND
MYSELF WERE ALL IN THE ROOM WHEN
HE TESTIFIED THAT THE DISCUSSION
INTERVIEW WITH THE FBI.
THEN WE LEARNED OF A MAY 2ND
MEMO
MEM
MEMO WRITTEN BY COMEY WITH THAT
DECISION WAS MADE 2 MONTHS
BEFORE.
THOSE TIMES OF DECISION OUT OF
THE ORDINARY IN THE FBI PROMPTED
THE NEED FOR AN INVESTIGATION
JUST REFERENCE INVOLVING THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IS TO GET
ANSWERS TO THE QUESTIONS
AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE LONG SOUTH.
WHO WILL YOU BRING IN TO DO
THOSE TRANSSCRIBED INTERVIEWS?
CONFIDENTIAL INTERVIEW.
I WOULD DESCRIBE IT AS
FOUNDATION INTERVIEW WITH ASKED
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHO, WHAT, WHERE
WITH RESPECT TO THE DECISIONS
MADE AT THE FBI AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT THAT WERE OUT OF THE
ORDINARY OR STANDARD PROTOCOL.
HE WAS ABLE TO PROVIDE US WITH A
NUMBER OF ANSWERS THAT WILL HELP
US IDENTIFY THE PEOPLE WE NEED
TO TALK TO.
HE WAS NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE
ANSWERS TO OTHER QUESTIONS.
WE WILL CONTINUE THIS PROCESS.
I THINK THE CHAIRMAN MAN AND I
AGREE THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
COME IN TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THERE IS A FACTUAL BASIS TO
BRING THEM IN AND GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLEAR UP
INCONSISTENCIES BETWEEN THE
TESTIMONY THEY PREVIOUSLY GAVE
TO CONGRESS AND THE DOCUMENTS
THAT HAVE NOW SURFACED.
>> CONGRESSMAN, WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND THE FBI IS SO MANY
ABNORMALITIES.
THINGS THAT WOULD NEVER HAPPEN
IN ANY OTHER SITUATION.
YOU HAVE BOTH BEEN PROSECUTORS.
WHAT IS DIFFERENT ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATION THAT WENT INTO
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DECISION
AND THE ANNOUNCEMENT?
WHAT IS THAT LAUNDRY LIST OF
THINGS THAT IS SO DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT NORMALLY HAPPENS DURING
DIFFICULT FACTS MAKE FOR
DIFFICULT CONCLUSIONS.
2016 WAS A REALLY DIFFICULT YEAR
FOR THE FBI.
PART WAS BECAUSE OF DECISIONS
THEY MADE AND PART WAS BECAUSE
OF THEY ARE TRYING TO CONDUCT AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE THROES OF
A PRESIDENTIAL RACE.
WHAT WAS DIFFERENT ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATION INTO SECRETARY
CLINTON?
ALMOST EVERYTHING.
I DON'T WANT TO LITIGATE THEIR
DECISION NOT TO CHARGE HER.
YOU CAN LIKE IT OR NOT LIKE IT.
NO ENTITY IS TOO BIG TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT OVER.
THE FBI AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE CAN WITHSTAND SCRUTINY.
IF YOU MADE THE DECISION NOT TO
CHARGE SOMEONE IN MAY OF 2016
OF THE INVESTIGATION, THEN YOU
HAVE TO EXPLAIN HOW YOU REACHED
THAT DECISION NOT TO CHARGE
I WANT TO KNOW ABOUT THE
IMMUNITY AGREEMENTS AND WHY YOU
ALLOWED FACT WITNESSES TO SIT IN
ON WITNESS INTERVIEWS.
I WANT TO KNOW WHY YOU WANTED
YOU USE THE GRAND JURY TO
THE GROUND RULES AND SAY I WILL
HAVE THESE FAMILY AND FRIENDS IN
THE ROOM.
THAT'S NOT THE WAY IT'S DONE FOR
DID YOU DO THINGS DIFFERENT IN
YOUR INVESTIGATION?
WE ALREADY THE ANSWER IS YES.
WHY DID YOU DO IT DIFFERENTLY IN
HER CASE?
THE BUREAU AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ARE BIG ENOUGH TO
WITHSTAND THOSE QUESTIONS.
>> THE INTEGRITY AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI IS UNDER
ATTACK.
PEOPLE BACK?
>> I THINK PART OF THE PROBLEM
ISSUES AS THE CHAIRMAN SAID IT'S
BEEN A BAD 18 MONTHS FROM THE
-- FBI.
SOME OF THESE PEOPLE ARE GONE.
WE HAVE TO CONDUCT THE OVERSIGHT
NECESSARY TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT
THEY ARE EFFECTIVE IN RESTORING
THE INDE
THE INTE
THE INTEGR
THE INTEGRIT
THE INTEGRITY
THE INTEGRITY O
THE INTEGRITY OF
THE INTEGRITY OF TH
THE INTEGRITY OF THE
THE INTEGRITY OF THE D
THE INTEGRITY OF THE DEP
THE INTEGRITY OF THE DEPAR
THE INTEGRITY OF THE DEPARTM
OFFICIALS LIKE FORMER DIRECTOR
COMEY AND ATTORNEY GENERAL
LYNCH, WE HOPE THEY HAVE
PLAUSIBLE EXPLANATIONS FOR ALL
OF THESE UNPRECEDENTED
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT CHAIRMAN JUST
DESCRIBED.
WE HOPE THEY DO.
IF THEY DON'T, WE ARE FACING A
CONSITUTIONAL CRISIS.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOR
DECADES TO COME.
I HOPE THAT THESE INVESTIGATIONS
THAT WE ARE CONDUCTING IN OUR
ROLE CAN SHED LIGHT ON.
THAT WE ARE NOT PROSECUTORS
ANYMORE.
I AM NOT ACCUSING ANYONE OF
AMERICAN PEOPLE AS THEIR ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES.
THAT'S WHAT ALL OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS ARE ABOUT.